In the previous video, you learned
that virtually every device that
communicates across the Internet
has a physical layer, and
these intermediate communication
protocol layers that sit on top of it,
in order to enable the transmission
of packets and data streams.
Sitting on top of these layers
is the application layer.
This layer is responsible for
setting all of the protocols in
which applications exchange data.
The most popular
application level protocol
is the Hypertext Transfer Protocol,
or HTTP.
HTTP functions via a series of requests
and responses between clients and
servers respectively.
You may be familiar with other
acronyms like FTP, IMAP, SSH, and POP.
These are also some other popular
application level protocols.
The original OSI model has the
application layer sitting as the highest
level set of protocols for
communicating across the Internet.
But other protocols and
technologies for sending and
receiving information
via APIs also exist.
In order to better understand and
organize these technologies,
I would like to introduce two more
layers to our existing model.
Let's call these two layers the web
service and message formatting layers.